concernant sanofi sur le fait que ce ne
soit pas conclusif malawi d'accord avec
sanofi bien sûr c'est ce que j'ai dit
dès le début
certainement aimé par contre c'est sur
la question de la sécurité quand vous
dites qu'il y à sept morts jusqu'à
preuve du contraire il n'y a pas du tout
de certitude que cette mort soit due à
un effet direct de la chloroquine et et
est par ailleurs les seuls effets qui
ont pu être observés ils ont été
relativement faibles et ils peuvent être
contrôlés ils peuvent être contrôlée
justement par des dosages et ils peuvent
être contrôlés dans le justement en
n'utilisant pas dans certains cas
extrêmes la chloroquine donc évidemment
ça veut dire c'est un médicament qui a
des effets des effets qui sont forts et
donc comme si ce sont des idées qui font
fort il faut prendre un certain nombre
de précautions précautions pour été
prise donc je vais vous dire vous dit ce
qui est fait à marseille c'est ces
vagues c'est pas sérieux etc
j'ai quand même des milliers de gens qui
sont passés par un parent par arias eu
des centaines qui ont été soignés alias
jeu donc on dispose malgré tout on a
beau dire ce qu'on veut on dispose je
veux dire par l'observation de paix d
évolution de ces malades on peut le
comparer on peut les comparer
statistiquement avec ce qui s'est passé
dans d'autres hôpitaux
on a encore c'est pas encore conclusive
mais il me semble que cela va plutôt
dans le sens du protocole qui était
utilisé à marseille alors après on peut
dire ce qu'on veut sur sanofi sanofi
sanofi
vous savez très bien que c'est
absolument pas une preuve un laboratoire
peut raconter absolument ce qu'il veut
c'est pas eux qui sont scientifiques
même s'il paye des scientifiques par
ailleurs ça pourrait être d'autre
intérêt à ce que sanofi fait aussi
d'autres d'autres mais d'autres
médicaments et ça serait pas si rentable
que ça pour sanofi devant diderot
chloroquine qui est un médicament qui
coûte à 30 40 50 60 fois moins cher qu'à
peu près tous les autres qui sont venus
proposer donc je veux pas rentrer dans
la question de théorie du complot mais
votre argument sur le laboratoire qui
dit que etc
un bon argument
[Musique]